no matter what your life circumstances
are
the
the message is
wake up
[Music]
i'm dave rubin and joining me on the
reuben report today is the
internationally best-selling author of
the power of now which has sold 12
million copies worldwide since it was
first published with translations into
52 languages along with his most recent
book a new earth which has already sold
over 15 million copies worldwide and has
been translated into 50 languages
eckhart tolle welcome to the reuben
report thank you
i am uh i am truly thrilled to have you
here and i suspect this is going to be
an interview like no other that i've
done do you have a preference for what
language since you've been translated
into basically every living language on
earth is english going to be okay for
the purposes of this i'll be happy with
english i wrote it in english
i do give talks sometimes in german and
spanish but uh before i do that i always
prepare myself in a read the german and
spanish translations of the book yeah
well all right we'll go with english uh
at least for the beginning portion of
this so
the way that you end up here because i
think people are going to go whoa this
is this is a little different than
what's going on in dave's garage usually
uh you came here by way of seeing an
interview that i did with my my friend
my mentor and really the guy that i
think is the best interviewer of all
time larry king i thought that would be
an interesting way of starting because
that that i think is how you got
introduced to me yes i've also been a
fan of larry king for many years and i
happened to come across your interview
with him on youtube
and i was very impressed not only by you
as an interviewer because you has you
have that openness
that many interviewers lack and that of
course larry king also has
and i was very impressed by some of the
things that larry actually said about
how he conducts the interviews he always
comes from a place of
curiosity from a place of
not knowing
from a place of wanting to find out the
interviewee's perspective
and most interviewers of course
come from a
they have a
mental position that they seek to
protect or they are trying to
prevail with their mental positions
they're not really interested in what
the interviewee has to say
so
after seeing that interview
oh i believe during the interview with
larry king i actually mentioned
he interviewed me a few weeks after
right right i watched that interview and
that was another coincidence
and when larry king interviewed me i
mentioned having seen
your interview with him
and then
our makeup artist
connected us because she works for larry
as well as for you yeah and here we are
and here we are all right well
i guess a good way to start for for the
few people watching that don't know you
uh can you just tell me a little bit
about your background and
until you were 29 years old uh
spirituality actually wasn't wasn't your
thing people are so associative of that
with you uh but can you just tell a
little bit about growing up
yes i grew up in
germany
out to the age of 15. 15
at 15 i left school i just couldn't
stand it anymore so i refused to go to
school
my parents had gotten a divorce my dad
had moved to spain
and my mom didn't know what to do with
me i was just hanging around at home
didn't want to go to school anymore so i
was saying to live with my dad in spain
where i lived for four years up to the
age of 19.
without going to school my dad was
always a very
unconventional person and he asked me do
you want to go to school i said no and
he said well then don't wow so what were
you doing i pursued my own interests i
read some which started reading
literature of course learning spanish
learning english i loved languages i
loved reading i loved literature
at 16 i started working part time
as a translator of restaurant menus
and then i became a tour guide i was 17.
i became a tour guide for
taking people around from cruise ships
around
the spanish town where we lived
and
then
at
19 i moved to england to work
in england i was immediately
i immediately felt at home that i have
to feel some deep connection with
england
and
i worked in england for
uh four years
full time
and became more interested in
intellectual things so i took all the
necessary exams that
were required to get into university
they called
well at the time they were called all
levels and a levels and so on so i took
those exams
and finally i got a
scholarship to get into the london
university where i studied modern
languages and literature
and
so that's the external
story
on the inside i
experienced increasingly
periods of terrible anxiety and
depression
even while i was working and while i was
a student
um
can you describe what that was to yes
it was uh
an inability to stop my mind my mind was
continuously racing along and creating
scenarios of
where i failed where i
lost even the little that i had
it went a lot into the past too where i
felt ashamed about things that happened
in the past
but not only that
there was a deeper existential
fear and an existential anguish
that's
hard to describe
it
it is a kind of alienation from the
world
alienation is probably the best word
where everything that you
come into contact with
feels
strange and alien or disconnected from
everything and everybody
and
that is something that
i believe many people these days suffer
from
although it has also existed
it has happened to isolated individuals
in the past
if you want to read about that state i
recommend
in the old testament there is the book
of ecclesiastes
which starts with the famous phrase
as in the old translation
vanity of vanities all is vanity
but what it really means if you use the
modern term
i would translate it as
everything is so effing pointless what's
the point of it all so that to be deeply
affected by the seeming
meaninglessness of life around you so i
remember when i went into a department
store in london
or walked along the streets
it seemed so
so absurd that people were buying all
these things and then
going out with their shopping bags full
of stuff
everything seemed so absurd and
meaningless almost producing
a kind of
nausea
and that's nausea is actually a novel by
jean-paul sartre where he describes that
state
so that's exactly how it is
um
it's it is described in various places
in world literature too
for example in anna karenina at the end
of the book just before she commits
suicide
the world the tolstoy describes how she
sees the world just before she commits
suicide and everything is just every
human being she sees is despicable and
dreadful and total disconnection from
the world around her
so that is the existential anguish that
i also experienced quite frequently did
you have a sort of rock bottom moment
with that was there a specific moment
that then started your turn around yes
uh
so i would often wake up in the middle
of the night in the state of panic or
fear
and
almost feeling breathless
and one night i woke up again on three
in the morning and
my mind was racing along
and then a strange thought came into my
mind that said i can't live with myself
any longer i can't live with myself any
longer
and after thinking that thought
there was a kind of this little shift
occurred i was standing back from that
thought so to speak
and i thought what a strange thought to
think i can't live with myself
am i one or am i too
who is that self that i cannot live with
and who am i so a kind of inner
separation occurred
and
i felt like of disappearing into a kind
of void
and the next morning i woke woke up and
i felt incredibly peaceful for some
reason i didn't understand why
it took me several years
to understand why from that point onward
there was always
in
sometimes in the foreground sometimes in
the background
the sense of inner peace no matter what
my outer circumstances were
but now i can actually explain what
happened that night
there was a
disidentification in my consciousness
from the
stream of
compulsive and incessant thinking
that most people have absolutely no
control over
people say i think but that is usually
not the case because thinking happens to
them
they have no control over it so it is
actually wrong to say i think it would
be the same as you are saying i'm
beating my heart
you're not beating heart it's done for
you it happens to you yeah so there was
this what i now call the voice in the
head
that i was completely identified with so
i was completely identified with the
stream of thinking that which is quite
normal for many people are
and
a lot of that stream of thinking was of
a negative nature
so
i did not experience the reality around
me
except through the veil
of negative self-talk the veil the
mental veil
of negatives of negative
labeling and interpretations
and i my whole what i consider to be my
life
i hadn't realized until i disidentified
what i took to be my life
was a narrative in my mind
and it consisted of certain things from
the past that i identified with things
that had happened to me
it was a
bundle of thoughts that recurred
continuously that
gave me my sense of self and it was an
unhappy sense of self it was a narrative
based sense of self
and
that night
i stood back from this narrative which
is
fueled by continuous thinking
i stood back
and i i realized for the first time a
dimension of consciousness within myself
that was deeper one could also say
higher depends how you want to look at
it
deeper than thinking
now this dimension of consciousness
that's deeper than thinking i now call
it awareness or sometimes call it
presence
and that exists in every human being but
most humans are not aware of it at all
they don't know that there is a deeper
dimension of consciousness in them
and that dimension
is
transcends thinking
it you experience it
uh
when the mind becomes still for a moment
this is what people want to achieve for
example when they meditate
it can also happen to you when you're
engaged in a dangerous activity like
mountain climbing
then you cannot be involved in thinking
you have to conceptual thinking stops
but
you do not lose consciousness
so the important thing is
there is a state of consciousness
possible in humans
where you are fully conscious
without the activity of conceptual
thinking
that's also the essence for example of
zen and i would suggest that it's
actually the essence of all spirituality
is to find
that state of consciousness in yourself
where you can be
alert and aware
but you there's no conceptualization in
your mind it doesn't mean it stays like
that for a long time you then go back
into thinking
but if you're able to access the
dimension in yourself
you are no longer possessed by your
thinking mind you are no longer used by
your thinking mind you are actually able
to
use your mind instead of being used by
your mind
as long as you are used by your mind all
your mental activity
is a reflection of the conditioning that
has happened to you so you take on the
conditioning from a personal on a
personal level from school parental
background and so in that conditions the
way that you think then you have the
collective conditioning around you you
take on the conditioning of the the
culture that you inhabit that's around
you
if you if you watch the media every day
then you take on those viewpoints and
that you think they are your thoughts
they are not your thoughts you you take
these thoughts on from the outside
and
they become
part of your identity
so identity is a key word because
identity
everybody
is extremely interested and
in finding
their identity
one could say that after
after meeting the
needs of food and shelter
almost
immediately after this come to search
for an identity
which already starts with a child when
the child has a toy that feels it
belongs to me it's my toy somebody takes
it away
there's great suffering in the child it
cries
because the child began to identify with
something and called it mind and that's
only the beginning of course
so please yeah next
well there's so many there's so many
things there that i that i want to jump
into so
well i guess first we we are going to
get to some of the techniques that you
use and that many other people use to to
attain
this sort of level of of peace and
separation from that that sort of
endless stream but do you do you think
that most people
whether they're conscious of it or not
are just all day long just sort of
spinning like a top out of control where
they they bounce in and out of this at
all times so you might do all sorts of
things during the day
uh that are distractions and you can get
upset about politics or do drugs or
waste time with this or that but then we
all have that voice in us that that sort
of knows
more of the right way to do things or
more of a peaceful way to do things but
we but we don't have any way
to really
i don't know is control the right word i
don't know if control is the right word
but we don't have any way to really
ascertain what's really happening yes uh
unless uh you're
you're completely neurotic or or even
clinically insane
you probably have some access i'm not
talking to you
it's okay
uh you can diagnose me at the end
if you're not if you're not
uh
continuously in a state of
confusion or anxiety or depression if
you're not
if you occasionally you feel okay you
feel occasionally happy
you probably have some access to that
dimension in yourself without knowing it
without recognizing it
so there are actually
we could describe this as moments in
your daily life
brief moments
when you're actually not thinking but
they're very they tend to be for most
people very brief
but they're very significant
these are moments perhaps you are
looking at something and you're looking
you might be looking at the tree or
flower or the sky and for a moment
there's three seconds when you take this
in completely often it's something
natural that you're looking at and
you're looking at the sky
and perhaps for the first three or four
seconds you're looking at it
you feel a sense of inner expansion
almost like coming to a to rest
and then perhaps after four five six
seconds the mind comes in and interprets
what you have just seen
i also find that people
find
enter that state without knowing it when
they relate to pets or to animals
when you meet a dog you look into the
eyes of the dog
now the dog is a conscious being but the
dog has no conceptual thinking
so when you look into the eyes of the
dog you instinctively realize that the
dog is not judging you in any way
because the dog had no concepts by which
to judge you
so you feel kind of when you look into
the eyes of the dog you feel a moment of
liberation from your from your
conceptual self because there you have a
being who has no conceptual self so
you're able to feel so to speak the
beingness the being of the dog
and that's and in that moment you're not
thinking
a few seconds of
inner spaciousness and then you it feels
good to be with this animal i call dogs
guardians of being
and
and so
another one is look into the eyes of a
one-year-old baby
when this baby is looking back at you
and this baby has not yet arrived at
conceptualization but there is obviously
a
luminous consciousness there and the
eyes of the baby can be just amazing
when the baby looks at you like this
and you feel wow
this touches you deeply
in that moment
you are free of conceptual thinking
because the baby is not thinking
conceptually and you are connecting with
this beautiful being
at a deeper level
so there are moments
when you are
naturally free
of this stream of thinking and those are
the most worthwhile moments
in your life ultimately it could happen
also when you're out in nature you're
hiking or you're you're doing some
physical activity
and you're not thinking very much you're
taking in or the world that surrounds
you the essential sensory perception
you're taking everything in you're
completely present whether you're in the
forest or on the mountain on the beach
you're completely present and suddenly
you feel so peaceful why do you feel so
peaceful do you feel so peaceful because
you are
out in nature well the indirectly yes
but the the real reason why you feel so
peaceful is that in that moment you are
conscious and consciously perceiving but
not thinking
do you think would you think one way to
describe it in in sort of simplistic
terms would be that when you're doing
sort of what you're supposed to be doing
that you can lock into that kind of
thinking because i can give you two
quick examples for myself i've had a few
moments in the hundreds of interviews
that i've done
where there's something where i can lock
eyes with someone and we are so right
here doing exactly where we're supposed
to be doing what we're supposed to be
doing that actually some of the
background almost gets a little bit
blurry i can i can feel i mean i can
feel a little bit of it right now
actually there's and you can't you can't
hold it it just it comes and goes and
all those things so i've had it in this
very room and then the other time that i
think i've had it was uh when i was
doing stand-up and there was one
particular night where i was killing i
mean i had the room in my hand and i
remember
seeing myself from behind myself it was
actually i could actually see the back
of myself
and i don't even remember what i was
saying but it almost was like slow
motion it was like yes this is what i
was supposed to be doing is that is that
a good way to find yes that can happen
when you are
engaged in an activity and certainly you
are guided
by an intelligence that is
greater than the collected information
that you have in your mind now that
intelligence that is i call it the
unconditioned consciousness whereas the
mind is the conditioned consciousness
that intelligence can use your mind and
then your mind becomes a creative tool
so and then you can be spontaneous in
for example in your presentation when
you're on stage and you will
come up with things that you could never
have thought of if they they come
because you're con connected
with a deeper level of consciousness
within yourself and that ultimately is
the way to live as much as nobody is
connected a hundred percent of the time
with that but to be connected with that
when you're engaged in your whatever
your main activity is that's an it's an
act of grace if you're able to do that
and then you are
empowered what whatever you do is
empowered by
something much greater than yourself
and what is that
it is i say you have access to
what i call issuance perhaps a little
bit mystical universal intelligence of
which the human mind is only one
expression there are countless
expressions of universal intelligence
and all spirit all the ancient spiritual
teachings they actually
point
that way may i
if i if you don't mind if i may enter
some interpret something that jesus said
which i believe is actually exactly the
same thing
uh
jesus often talks about
the kingdom of heaven interesting
expression and i there's a line which i
opened the bible the other day and i saw
the line it said jesus went from village
to village and from town to town and
said
repent for the kingdom of heaven is at
hand. and the the whole thing is already
contained there
repent means it's miss it's a
mistranslation repentance the original
greek is metanoia
which means a turnaround a shift a
complete shift
so the repentance so people think of it
as apologize or something like that yeah
that's all you beat yourself up i'm such
a miserable sinner
that's not that's a missing the
misinterpretation of repentance started
when it was translated into latin
into latinos penitentia which was
already wrong
and now we have
metanoia as repentance no
a complete reversely complete turnaround
in other words a shift in consciousness
repent now what does he mean by the
kingdom of heaven now christians
traditionally believed it's something
that's going to come
that's the belief they completely
overlooked when they asked jesus
when when does the kingdom of heaven
come
he said
the kingdom of heaven does not come with
observation
in another translation it says the
kingdom of heaven does not come with
signs to be perceived you cannot say
it's over here or it's over there for
the kingdom of heaven is within you
now
what is that thing that's within you
where you can never say
it's there or it's there
i i re-translate kingdom of heaven into
modern terminology
for kingdom i substitute dimension
and heaven what is heaven when you look
up into heaven you see the vast sky the
spaciousness of the sky
he used that analogy to point to an
inner reality he used because the
language usually refers to external
things that you can see and touch
so the closest that jesus could find in
the external world to point to something
in the inner realm
was to look at the vast spaciousness of
the sky which in itself has no
particular form but it's amazing
and he said
the kingdom of heaven then
is heaven my translation is spaciousness
inner spaciousness which is
the uncluttered mind consciousness
without
conceptual without thought it's inner
alert stillness
the dimension of spaciousness
find that dimension of that's the
primordial teaching in jesus find that
within yourself find the kingdom of
heaven find the dimension
of inner spaciousness
where you're able to be
alert
and still
completely conscious
but not thinking
and that's the essence of jesus teaching
to find that when you find that
then you re when you
relate to other human beings
you can sense the same dimension in the
other human although they have a
personality which is a conditioned self
but underneath so to speak the
personality there is a deeper being and
that deeper being is their
unconditioned consciousness but it's not
consciousness is not a personal thing
so when i look at you
first thing i would see is your
personality and of course the physical
body and the personality whatever makes
up your personality but if i look more
deeply and not just look but actually
sense your presence i know that beyond
your personality there is an essence in
you that is one with the essence in me
and one could describe it as
consciousness itself
the essence of who you are
the essence of who i am is consciousness
when i recognize that consciousness
the same consciousness that in me this
consciousness beyond the conditioned
self
recognizes the consciousness in you that
which is beyond your conditioned self
and that recognition
is what jesus called love
and therefore he said
love thy neighbor as thyself
but
that as a separate statement it doesn't
work but when you put it together with
kingdom of heaven that it reads
find the kingdom of heaven within you
the dimension of spaciousness
then you will
recognize your neighbor which is anybody
that you are with
then you will recognize him or her
as yourself
and this recognition that in essence you
are one that you are
deeply deeply connected that you share
the con the one consciousness when you
recognize and in the other then you have
suddenly an outflow of benevolence and
good will and love
not the ego love but true love towards
the which in the old testament in the
new testament agape spiritual love for
another human being you can sense their
very beingness
so and that's the whole secret of the of
of all spirituality it's in jesus in the
teaching of jesus um it is
so the the our purpose here
beyond the personal purposes that we
have everybody has their personal
purpose the work you do whatever it is
there's a deeper purpose that the
personal purpose must be aligned with
and that deeper purpose is to live from
that deeper place
the way i interpret
you know in the english language doesn't
have a word that describes both men and
women it's the german language has
mensch which is also used in yiddish to
the german word it has mens means both
man or woman
for a long time i regret it that the
english language doesn't have a word for
a human you have to say human being but
now i'm happy that i have to say human
being because that describes exactly the
two dimensions
the human is a conditioned self it's a
personality your historical person which
comes from the past based on past who
you are as a person that
includes your physical body and your
psychological self
i call that sometimes your form identity
there's a physical form
and there's a psychological form of you
that's the human
and then there's a being the being is
the deeper self that is
consciousness
unconditioned
and
no human life is fulfilled
unless
the human has at least some access
to this dimension within them
that really is the ultimate purpose to
at least
maybe not complete access but at least
to have glimpses of
that which transcends the self to have
glimpses of self transcendence in your
life if you you
no matter how successful you are in this
world
if you have never had even a glimpse of
self-transcendence
then your life is pretty
purposeless and and it's very unlikely
that you will be a happy human being
is the ultimate paradox with all of this
that it's almost impossible to hold on
to so even someone that has spent their
life
uh trying to attain that state uh that
you can't hey you can't you to function
and as a human
maybe not as a human being but just as a
human uh
it would be almost impossible to
constantly be in that state in a world
that doesn't exist in that state yes not
constantly but it is possible to
to e to not just have that when you are
perhaps let's say engaged in spiritual
practice or you're meditating or when
you're out in nature and
unhappy moments out in nature it it is
our task to as much as possible
incorporate that deeper level of
consciousness into our daily life even
if we don't succeed all the time
that's fine that's part of the practice
so
one could say then
our purpose in our daily life beyond the
personal purpose which is also important
because we need to honor
who we are as a person too and we need
to honor our identity as a person
because no doubtedly that exists and
whatever it is that makes up your
identity whether it's mostly a personal
kind
whether you identify with a certain
collective around you it could be your
religion whatever it might be
uh
or the culture that you grow up in that
has its place that that's nothing wrong
with it but if that is all you know
about yourself that's very limiting
so you honor it but there's more to you
than that
and that's why the ancient greeks said
starting from pythagoras
500 bc
know thyself the most perhaps the most
important dictum in ancient greek
philosophy which was carved carved on
the
walls of the temple of apollo at delphi
know thyself
very deep saying
who who you are in your essence
so because you have the form identity
which is a personality the for and you
hasn't have as i call it an essence
identity
and so to know yourself as this essence
is
it called in in in indian
some in some india indian spiritual
philosophy is called self-realization
so you know
and and then
the practice becomes in daily life
to as much as possible
live from that dimension
for example
another countless examples one could
give
very simple things
like i recommend for example
whenever you are waiting for something
at the elevator or you're in the
elevator or you're waiting for a phone
call or you're waiting in line somewhere
at the airport you're waiting this like
quite a bit of time we spend waiting
traffic lights you're waiting now these
days mostly people get out their phone
when they're waiting because this means
there's a
continuously your mind is being
cluttered more and more i call it
clutter clutter is useless information
they get often they get out their phone
they don't know why
they get out their phone because
somebody next to them is getting out
their phone and then they start
switching around
there's a there would be a moment
whenever you're waiting
an opportunity to in that moment to
declutter your mind and
create a little bit of inner
spaciousness the kingdom of heaven the
dimension of spaciousness
for example
this is very ancient and very simple
method
by becoming aware that you are breathing
you're becoming i call it it's a mini
meditation one conscious breath
which is the in-breath
and you follow the breasts with your
attention
you feel it the air moving into the body
you might even feel it
into your evening to your abdomen the
energy and then you breathe out
one and what does that do why is it so
important
when you're aware of your breathing you
take attention away from thinking
you cannot be completely aware of your
breathing and think at the same time you
can either think or be aware of your
breathing so that's a quick way of
having a little bit of spaciousness in
your life one conscious past maybe two
conscious breaths
everybody has time for one or two
conscious breaths from time to time
during the day nobody is so busy that
this guy cannot take
six seven or eight seconds
for contact although the mind might tell
you no i have too much to do it's a lie
don't believe every thought that comes
into your head
and then you create spaciousness the
more spacious and you create the more
effective your thinking will be when you
start thinking again
because then thinking can link into this
creative intelligence
that is the unconditioned intelligence
in you and then it can be inspired by
that
i would suggest every creative person
would create something really new
uh had some access to that dimension in
in the area of their creative endeavor
probably not in the rest of their lives
they may be
as crazy as everybody else in the rest
of their lives
but when they engage in their act of
creation
they have access to their dimension and
that's a this is
once you you touch this power within you
which is not egoic power it's not power
over somebody else
it's primordial the power of life itself
when you can sense that within yourself
that becomes the basis for your sense of
who you are
and no longer the story in your mind
and and that's the shift
so you become free of identity
having to completely identify with your
past deriving consensus we are from your
historical past which is
most people's past is just a very mixed
bag and there's a lot of it that you may
not like
instead of that your sense of who you
are comes from a deeper place
and that resolves all questions of
what people are concerned with
self-esteem
self-confidence people go to
therapists to build up their self-esteem
because it's not high enough but once
you touch that
level of consciousness within yourself
self-esteem comes from there but it's
not comparative anymore
then you can sense the power that dwells
within you
and you don't need to compare yourself
to somebody else and say i'm powerful
because i have more than this person
you know in essence
every human has that but they mostly
don't know it
but it's there
as a siege one could say in every human
being
it's just it's so wonderful this
realization
where does where does past guilt which i
think you're sort of referencing let's
fit into this because we mentioned right
before we started that i've been on tour
with jordan peterson and during the q
and a's i see so many people that will
say to him you know i just read your
book and i'm applying the 12 rules for
life and my life is better my
relationship's better i'm not doing
drugs whatever whatever it may be i've
mended relationships et cetera et cetera
um but they have trouble getting over
some sort of past
guilt yeah and i think what you're
describing here is
the first step in getting away from that
but i think a lot of people think it's
something that you can do like this
right but but it's not no you need to
recognize
where it comes from how it arises in you
of course guilt is related to grievance
well when it refers to another person
it's a grief and you have a resentment
or a grievance towards another person
when it refers to yourself
then it's called guilt but it always
refers to something
that was that either you did to somebody
that you now recognize as
bad in some way
not ethical
you did something perhaps when you were
younger perhaps you brought up your
children in a way that you now recognize
as
dysfunctional in some ways
or you injured somebody or you inflicted
suffering on somebody whether it's
emotional suffering mental suffering
even physical suffering
in extreme cases you might even have
killed somebody in a very
extreme cases and that brings about
guilt now guilt is
uh
something that you did that you now
recognize as
bad
this becomes a thought form in your head
and becomes incorporated into your sense
of self
what you don't realize is
you did something because you didn't
your consciousness your level of
consciousness
at that time
manifested that kind of behavior
no human being can
manifest behavior that's beyond their
level of consciousness
so if you inflicted harm on somebody
the ego tends to then make it into an
identity for yourself
and that brings about guilt when you see
the my that this is your essential self
is guilty
that can be a huge
ego boost
it can also be a huge eager boost to
declare somebody else as guilty
and somebody who did something to me so
people carry a grievance
or resentment sometimes for many many
years
and then again what they are doing is
they're transforming somebody's i call
it unconscious behavior when you inflict
suffering on another human being except
of course self-defense or whatever but
you inflict suffering on any life form
or a human being
you do it it's it's unconscious you as
jesus is supposed to have said on the
cross
forgive them for they know not what they
do
translated into modern terminology is
they are unconscious they know not what
they do
so people do all kinds of things
sometimes
in states after they've taken drugs they
become even more unconscious or they've
consumed alcohol they become makes you
more unconscious even
more unconscious than normal
unconsciousness
by unconscious by the way and perhaps
need to explain what i mean by
unconscious which is in spiritual terms
in conventional usage unconscious means
obviously you're right of lost
consciousness but in spiritual terms
unconscious means you are at the mercy
of the conditioning of your mind and
your emotions
the ways in which your emotions have
been conditioned
you're being run by that conditioning
there's no way that this human being has
any awareness of their conditioning
there's no awareness whatsoever and a
human human being who has zero awareness
uh perhaps not to
throughout their lives in moments when
they are
very unconscious they get triggered by
something as i said they take drugs
whatever they become zero awareness
and then they do what they do
later you look back on that and and then
you erroneously incorporate
that time of your life when you you
weren't even there you were run by an
automatic program in your mind and in
your emotional field
you weren't even there
but the ego will transform it into an
identity and says i i did this is now
part of who i am or it will do to
somebody else
there was a long time when i had
resentment towards my father because my
father
was pretty unconscious except
very late in life had a very strong ego
and living with him as a child
uh was living with an unexploded
bomb that could go off at any moment we
got these intense rages would suddenly
come
several times a week
so i lived in a constant state of
kind of a
background anxiety but is when is this
bomb going to explode again next
and then for a long time it was in my
twenties
i had a resentment towards him
until i went to the shifting
consciousness and i suddenly realized
he
he did what he had to do but there
wasn't enough awareness act any
different
so he was at the mercy of his own
conditioning
and once you see that you no longer make
it into an identity for him
and so you free him
and really perhaps this is the meaning
of forgiveness
you can forgive yourself
by not making unconscious behavior in
your past
into an identity
for yourself or for somebody else
now a question may arise
this is an interesting point now does
that mean
people are not really responsible for
that they do
so that's that's an interesting question
in ultimate terms it can say it is true
they are not responsible for what they
do but
they will have to suffer the
consequences of their unconsciousness
because we humans are meant to become
more conscious here
and one of the ways or even one of the
perhaps the main way in which a very
unconscious human
evolves eventually
or potentially
is by suffering the consequences of
their unconsciousness and sometimes the
consequences might be
they have to go to prison
it doesn't so
but it does
even if you meet a prisoner it's
important
if they did something in the past they
let's say
they killed somebody in the past of
course they have to suffer the
consequence of their own consciousness
but when you meet a human being like
that you can still
you may be able to to sense that there's
more to this human being than this this
unconscious person
so
uh how does that play into your
perspective on free will then
free will ultimately
does not come in until there's some
awareness in you that's where free will
comes from
until you have some awareness
you are run by the
conditioning of your mind
and so you have no choice
the element of choice comes in when you
become aware for example of your the
thoughts that go through your head and
you might realize suddenly and for some
people that's the first time they awaken
spiritually when they realize
that for years they've had a voice in
their head talking to them
which could be a monologue it could be a
dialogue
you could have a conversation with
yourself you can
you can beat yourself up and say why why
you you're no good enough aren't you and
then it's on the part of yourself is
well well i'm doing my best i'm just i
can't
i can't do it i'm not i'm not good
enough
the voice in the head
for some people the spiritual awakening
comes when they become aware that
there's a voice in the head and there's
the awareness right at the moment
there's awareness you might even be able
to choose
to let go of a certain thought a
repetitive thought that you don't need
anymore that you don't want anymore and
then you you surrender it
or you breathe it out you don't need it
you reckon an emotion
sometimes people and the grip of strong
emotions but if there's a little bit of
awareness there if let's say it's anger
you're suddenly anger arises
but in the background you're aware that
this emotion of anger so there's a small
element of choices come in do you want
to
then
attack this person
if there's awareness you can observe the
anger but may mean longer may no longer
need to act it out
i'm not talking about suppressing
but recognizing
the more awareness you have or presence
the more choice there is in your life
and then it's only then that you
actually become truly intelligent
because
this awareness is not an iq thing
the way you can have
i've met highly intelligent people with
one or two or three phds
academics and others were completely
completely unaware still just completely
in their minds
and
people
in their personal lives often very
dysfunctional personal lives
uh so it's not to be equated with
intelligence this awareness
um
it's uh
what do you make of that life actually
so if there's someone that exists in
that state all the time but then becomes
an uh you know a world-changing
scientist or mathematician or
or athlete or whatever it takes they
have to stay in that whether it's
consciously or not they have to stay in
that mode of thinking
what do you make of that life that maybe
doesn't
lock in to hearing the the the inner
voice
well it can be a very extremely
unbalanced life uh
no matter how intelligent they are even
people who have there are some people
who are very creative in one area but
the rest of their lives is completely
unbalanced
and then some people are almost
destroyed by the
by the um the lack of balance in their
lives like famous people like
even
some famous pop artists who
were quite
quite creative in the way
michael jackson for example
um as a person he's just just
he's just
i mean he's passed away now but i
remember seeing him in interview as a
person he's just a lit guy's got much to
say in his teammate and he's and
but the moment he moves he makes a dance
movement or just a power flows through
him
and
i saw that
but this
the important thing is the
the
the this
that this
creative intelligence needs to
come into the into the rest of your your
knife needs to become a work of art a
creative work of art not just a little
area in your life
so what the world needs
is actually not more intelligence
it doesn't need more knowledge like i
mean we're just
we're drowning in facts and information
and we don't need more of that
to use an old-fashioned word
what the world needs is wisdom
wisdom is
inseparable from awareness it arises out
of awareness
without wisdom
you are torn
you may be identified
with the the polarities of life that
perhaps worth mentioning here
you know the ancient yin and yang
chinese
way of looking at the world they see the
yin is the feminine principle and the
young is the masculine principle so
these the polarities are everywhere in
life this is a very for western mind is
a very strange way of looking at things
but the the chinese philosophy ancient
chinese philosophy says
the
there's an uh
play of the the world is a manifestation
of the play between yin and yang the the
feminine masculine principles you may
remember the symbol of yin and yang
and
here too you can be you can be in the
grip
of a particular energy movement
without awareness you can get into the
grip of yang
and then you would become
quite destructive if you go to an
extreme
a country
can be in the grip of yang energy
like
germany was russia china any country
where this dictatorship
is in the grip of an extreme grip of
yang
traditionally
society
in
at least in the west has been
dominated by the young energy
with occasional interludes of yin in
between but relatively insignificant for
example the romantic movement in the
19th century in
art and literature was some yin coming
in but not for too long
so would you put the enlightenment in as
a yen state
in enlightenment there was a bit of yin
coming in yes
yes
but
the first half of the 20th century was
an extreme manifestation of yang the
world wars the genocide in in germany in
russia in china cambodia
and other places
absurd unconsciousness yang of a yank
then
the world the western world especially
experienced
as a reaction to the extreme yang
an influx of yin it started in the 60s
actually a very strong influx of yin
and with that came
uh
the woman's women's movement and all
those things
more empathy towards other human beings
came in also an openness to
towards spirituality more instead of the
rigid patterns of institutionalized
religion
there was an openness towards the influx
also of eastern spirituality coming into
the west
there was an empathy over with
this is where the embassy with with a
disadvantaged humans came from an
empathy to the suffering of
people who are
physically
disabled be mentally disabled or
the so-called marginalized all those
things this is a wonderful thing human
could sense their suffering so more
empathy came up and this was a great
thing and a necessary thing
education changed completely from being
dominated by the young energy discipline
and young
and now education became more and more
permissive you do your own things it
became so permissive that eventually
there was no structure anymore at all
and schools became chaotic and family in
many families became totally chaotic
and so and the wonderful empathy towards
other human beings turned into political
correctness
quickly the world was moving towards an
extreme of yin
and to counterbalance but there was no
awareness so people first were in the
grip of the yang movement and identified
with that as a collective
and now a significant portion of western
civilization not all but a significant
portion of the population
is in the grip of a yen movement and
it's not stopping
it's going to an extreme
where
something that was initially good and
necessary yeah now trans anything that
goes to an extreme becomes destructive
and
another ancient saying in greek
philosophy is
nothing in excess
nothing in excess
so
now
the collective is is in the grip
not all of it but
to give in part the especially the
uh the mass of the media
universities and so on are strongly in
the grip of yin
germany is a interesting example
they like to go to extremes they were an
extreme of yang
they became the most aggressive country
in europe
and now
they're going into extreme of yin they
are the most compassionate country in
europe except sweden
the most common they open their borders
completely so please we want to help you
this is this is
this consists of two things there is the
compassion that arises when yin comes in
there is another element that needs to
be mentioned yes there is also guilt
which
plays its part too it's a combination of
of guilt and yen energy so
yen is symbolized as this
this is yin
receptive open
this is yang
you can see yang is the masculine the
thrusting principle it's almost a sexual
jin
yang
so
yang says
let's close the borders
on an extreme form of yang says let's
expand our country and then close the
borders let's attack the neighboring
countries and then we'll be even bigger
uh
the extreme of yen says no borders at
all
anyway you can walk and
this it's it it feels so good to be able
to say
how can you deny human beings who want a
better life how can we deny it feels so
wonderful to say that
but what's lacking is wisdom compassion
is there and it's wonderful
so you have
yin and yang
what's missing is it they need to
instead of
two polarity so you need to be a
triangle at the apex of the triangle you
need to have awareness
if there's enough awareness then you
don't need to go to an extreme of either
yin or yang
you know it's so interesting because i
wasn't really planning on doing anything
sort of political with you but actually
i think in the last few minutes you've
given me as good political analysis to
sort of where we are so without getting
into the
nitty-gritty of politics
if your premise is basically right
and this is why i always say the road to
hell is paid with good intentions the
people that i'm frustrated with right
now that you're describing as yin i
don't believe they're evil people there
can be there can be bad actors within
that let's say or people that aren't
acting in their conscious but i don't
believe that the bulk of them are
but if we're act if we're right now
we're caught between this
how how does the good decent person that
i think most people are that can check
in and out of their higher self and all
of those things but that want a decent
world
how do we how do we help these sides to
get to that place well first you have to
be careful with yourself so that you
don't get do not get drawn to either one
or the other extreme because now the
reactive mode of going to fine to yin
is would be to go too far into yang
and so
a
society that
goes totally into yin would produce
fascism again
that's the danger so the individual
needs to be aware that they don't go
into reactivity so that you remain aware
so you don't contribute
to the polarization in the world so what
what what you contribute whether it's on
the social media or in person
when you speak to somebody or you write
something
be careful that you do not confuse also
somebody's
mental emotional position which may be
either there or there
with who they are and then regard them
as an enemy the ego feels strengthens
the more enemies it can have the
stronger it feels there's always the
tendency the unconscious ego
to make others into enemies
so it's we need to develop
enough awareness to be able to conduct a
conversation with another human being
without regarding the other who might
hold very very different mental
positions as an enemy
i was very happy to see recently uh
happened to see an interview
on youtube with a guy who has come quite
a long way russell brand
has come a long way with um he's doing
great things now if anybody who hasn't
seen him for a long time should see him
again he met with
uh candice owens oh i saw it i thought
and then it's actually pretty incredible
they had an interview
he's on the left
she's on the right
they were
in many ways
opposing opposite viewpoints
respected each other as human beings
without making the other into an enemy
that is a wonderful stuff if they can do
it
like other people not do it
it just requires a little bit of
awareness
so that you can then
have a conversation
and it's only by having a conversation
that uh
you can find somewhere a middle a
middleweight something this is a
buddhist expression buddhism is called
the middle way
you find the middle way somewhere i um
if we don't have conversations with
others who have different viewpoints
then
the uh
there will be deterioration and
eventually
there would it might even be violence
so it's interesting because i know you
talk a lot about the collective
conscious which obviously i mean look
you happen to see me on youtube that
brought us here now your message can get
out to you know tons of other people and
all of that stuff which is absolutely
incredible so that's the that's the
great part of the internet that i think
has fed the collective unconsciousness
unconscious but then there's another
part of it where we seemingly are just
fighting all day long and you mentioned
before we're distracted all day long so
if we're standing on a corner we
automatically go to our phone do you
think that level of distraction and
technology and our
our adolescence relative to knowing what
is really going on by having the world
in your pocket at all times do you think
that is leading us to to a sort of
strange existential crisis that actually
could have never happened before just
because of the the speed with which yes
we can communicate and learn and and
hate and all of those things yes well
there's both what is commun
what is communicated through these
devices
but the very fact that there is this
device this was
many years ago there was a book by
marshall mcluhan it says the medium is
the message it was about television
but the
the nature of the device itself
we we need to be very careful
because what it does
is it contributes to the
clutter of our minds
so no matter
potentially uh
it it can be a very beneficial thing to
connect with humans through these
devices but at the moment the dangers
that
might be destructive are greater
i can see what it does to children who
from an early age interact with these
they're no longer able to
have personal relationships increasing
number of children have attention
deficit disorder
they now what is attention deficit
disorder they can't focus on anything
for very long anymore
what does that do to human consciousness
what does it do to a civilization
if humans grow up now
without the ability
to
focus on tension for very long because
ending any creative act requires you
to be present with something for period
of time to give it attention
and if humans lose the ability to give
attention
then they lose the ability to be
creative
if they lose the ability to be creative
they lose the ability even to solve
their problems because the problems that
they have created
it requires wisdom
and true creativity to solve those
problems
so all kinds of scenarios are possible
the
scenario of a breakdown of civilization
within two generations is a possibility
but
these things if these things are
we need to learn how to use these
devices
in the same way that we have to learn
how to use our minds because they're an
extension of our minds
so if we become more aware of what our
mind is doing then
it might be easier also to to handle
these devices because they are an
extension and amplification
of the mind
and the dysfunction that we see on the
internet with all these
dysfunctional behavior and so on it's
just it's an externalization and an
amplification
of the dysfunction of the human ego
you can just see it much more clearly
now it's all for everybody to see
and that might be a good thing to see it
because then we can really aware of it
what are we doing to ourselves that's a
good question to ask what are we doing
to ourselves this is becoming insane and
the moment you see that it is insane
then there's some sanity in you
because nobody who knows they're insane
is completely insane
the really insane people don't know
they're insane
so if you see the insanity in the way
that we collectively communicate you say
okay i'm not going to be part of that
it's necessary to see it and then your
responsibility as an individual is not
to feed it to stay conscious to stay
present so that your input
is conscious and does not
seek to destroy other human beings and
demonize other you dehumanize and
demonize other human beings so you view
that really as the antidote let's say to
the mob culture that we have because
there is this you can feel this you know
it's funny this morning i was scrolling
your twitter feed and it and your
twitter feed is is basically a breath of
fresh air it's like
when i was reading it there's like a
breath and it's and it's pleasant and
you know there's there's some of your
sayings and some of the ways that you
want to help people think clearly all
those things but that's so the reverse
of the way most of twitter is and i'm
part of that other world and and
sometimes sometimes i feed it and i try
not to but you know
i'm not perfect either um but i do see
this thing where where the mob is sort
of moving around on twitter and
sometimes it comes to get me too and
there's this there's an innate human
feeling you see something and it has a
lot of attention and it's shiny and it's
whatever and that everyone wants to get
in
but basically you're saying if you would
take that breath if you would just say i
don't want in on this
that eventually
you can actually you can almost pull
other people out of it too by your own
behavior yes because this isn't just
about you yes
also not to feed
other if other people post negative
things about you in many many cases
non-reaction is the best thing instead
of feeding it that's a lesson i need to
learn i will try to take that one with
me that applies both
offline and online in your personal life
too often it's just well
i believe jesus was talking about
non-reaction when he's talked about
turning the other cheek i don't think
it's to be taken literally
but it means when somebody
somebody attacks you not not physically
it's an analogy he uses a it's a parable
uh
to on the other seat it
means to just be free of reaction
and that uh that uh
very quickly
deflates even the other person's ego it
doesn't the ego needs the reaction it
needs the reactivity
so that's a powerful thing but how do
you avoid then just becoming a pushover
within that well in some situations
something needs to be said
but even then that can come from you
could say
let's especially with you with somebody
that kind of behavior is unacceptable
you can say that
in a
conscious way
rather than
in a destructive and aggressive way you
can one can actually be very firm and
conscious
or when you say no to somebody
it doesn't have to be
aggressive
it's just really a
clear it's i call it a high quality no
somebody says can you lend me again i've
uh
the
two thousand dollars i need i know i
still owe you twenty thousand but i need
some more and then and then not to make
the other into an enemy just no i'm
sorry can't do it anymore it's a high
quality no that's a
you're present while you say it
and then you can set boundaries if
necessary
so in some cases
something needs to be said we need to do
something but in many other cases
complete non-reactivity can be very very
powerful
what gives you the most amount of joy in
your life now the little things in life
the little things walking around in
nature
sometimes
sitting quietly in a room just being
i love being
nature
i still enjoy traveling and the greatest
joy is
teaching
giving talks
because that's my life purpose
and so once every every time i'm engaged
in my life purpose then i'm really in a
state of joy and
heightened aliveness
and uh
that's why i'm still doing it yeah would
you say you're
are you an optimist inherently
uh as far as
human destiny is concerned you mean or
humanity or in general yeah i don't mean
it personally actually i mean it just in
the in the wider world are you hopeful
oh yes i'm i'm optim i'm well i
sometimes call it i'm a long-term
optimist
i always say world weary optimism
short term i don't know it's possible
who knows where humanity is going right
now nobody could predict where it's
going
all the individual or the individual can
only take responsibility for their own
state of consciousness but that matters
very much
because your state of conscience
determine determines the way in which
you experience reality and that has many
repercussions you affect many other
humans through your state of
consciousness
so that's don't underestimate the
importance
of your state of consciousness in the
present moment
there's so much more we could do here
but i want to be respectful of your time
so i'll ask you one more and then when
we end this i'm going to beg you to come
back
but if someone's watching this right now
and is really in what jordan peterson
would describe as the state of chaos or
the state that you were in in in your
late 20s before you had your awakening
and they hear you and they say well just
you know taking that first breath isn't
going to do it if they're really just
out of sorts right now
what would be some
some way that you think you could help
shake them out of it give them something
concrete that would help them click you
know
stop on this thing and
and fix themselves or begin the process
let's say yeah yeah
well um
the best starting point is the present
moment
now whatever i say
any advice i give
it's quite possible if not likely that
their conditioned mind will deny what i
say and it'll say that's not going to
work so don't believe
what i say now if your mind says this is
not going to work don't believe what
your mind says just try what i've got
what what i'm saying now
so
we become more fully conscious of the
present moment right now because that's
that's all there ever is
your entire life
is experienced and unfolds in the
present moment
most humans
don't seem to even realize that because
they always live as if some other moment
where more important than this one
you need to honor this moment it's the
basis
for the so-called
for the future how that unfolds which
never comes
because when it comes it's the now
and the past never happened except when
you remember it it's over and you
remember it now so come into the present
moment
be aware of your breathing
and another one i recommend anybody this
we're actually very powerful if it
sounds almost too simple
but it's very powerful
feel the aliveness inside your body
and if you don't know what i mean i'll
usually i advise people to close their
eyes hold their hand like this and ask
themselves
without looking at my hand or moving my
hand how can i know whether my hand is
still there
that question requires you to direct
attention into your hand and then after
a few seconds you'll probably feel a
little bit of a tingling or liveness in
your hand
that is the beginning of
being able to feel what i call the inner
body this is the the energy field that
the
that pervades every cell in the body if
you can start with the hands
then you feel your legs
your feet your hands simultaneously
and then you incorporate the totality of
your body and so your attention is moved
from your mind you've taken
consciousness
into the body so one could say
you're now inhabiting
your body consciously
and when you it's a very very lovely
feeling
and you'll notice that you're no longer
thinking very much you can't
and all the
the problems that you have to a large
extent
we are created by dysfunctional thinking
and the emotions that accompany
dysfunctional thinking
most of the problems reside in your mind
so
if you are able to
become more present
then you access
a higher or deeper dimension of
consciousness and to become more present
you have to be able to step out of your
mind without losing
consciousness so the consciousness
goes into the body and the body becomes
an anchor
you can hold it through several minutes
at a time becomes an anchor for being
present
become as present as you can also
present of sense perceptions it's very
important sense perceptions can also
bring you
into the present moment an expression
you could use is come to your senses
in both meanings of the word expression
come to your senses look around
be consciously take everything in
without label it needing to label it
mentally
and then you suddenly aware of your
surroundings
you're aware of your inner energy field
you're in the present moment
and in the present moment there's no
problem it can't be there's not an
emergency sometimes yes then you have to
act but it's not an emergency he is no
problem
then your ability to deal with your
so-called problems
becomes
a
much greater
if you're able to access the power of
your presence
then when you choose to deal with your
problem say okay now apply focused
thought what can i do
when you return to presence it's always
going
thinking
back into learn what presence is
it's there
it's
the the kingdom of heaven is
at hand said it's right here it's right
here don't look for it elsewhere
and then you realize the
um
a lot of the
unhappiness in one's life
the buddha called it dukkha suffering he
says
every human suffers unless they
have awakened
but and a lot of the suffering is
not due to your life circumstances
although most people think it is
the larger part of your suffering is due
to
your mental commentary about your life
circumstances
your mind is telling you something that
creates the unhappiness
even you can test it out in a simple
situation you're in line somewhere you
get irritated it's taking too long
you're waiting
you get very angry and irritated
then experiment how would i experience
this situation without adding any
thought to it
if i didn't add any thoughts to this
moment just and then suddenly
oh it's actually fine
it's not before you were unhappy but you
were not unhappy because you had to wait
you weren't happy because of the
narrative in your mind so there are
millions of people who carry very toxic
narratives in their mind and they call
it my life
that's not
it's it's a terrible burden they carry
around it doesn't have to be like that
and the essence of all spirituality
is to be able to step out of that
realize if only a little bit of
self-transcendence which is inner
spaciousness
and then that grows
and then you can begin to sense there is
a power in you
that transcends the person
and that is also the place where you can
transcend
the uh
the feelings of
happiness and unhappiness which
fluctuate continuously i'm not saying
it's not happiness that you ultimately
find happiness is a little bit
superficial
yeah i made it and the next day or the
the opposite
it's something that transcends happiness
and unhappiness it's a deep sense of
rootedness in being of a deep sense of
inner peace
that really have has nothing much to do
with your personal circumstances i've
had letters from people in prison
who have written to me said i feel free
now because i've read your book and i've
practiced it
and my life is transformed and now i'm
teaching others
i feel many letters from prison
prisoners
so it's it's
no matter what your life circumstances
are
the the message is
wake up
wake up out of
complete identification with your mind
and so
that's your the ultimate purpose in life
is to awaken
this has been an absolute pleasure i
think that i i'm not i think i know that
i had a few of those brief leading
moments while we were here and i thank
you for that and i think if my audience
gets even one percent of that
through the internet waves that go out
there i think this will will be
something that i will always remember i
hope we can do this again because we
think we just started here
i normally
tell the twitter handle of my guest but
in this case i'm going to look at the
camera and tell you guys just to take a
breath
[Music]